let me stretch your memory back a whole
what - anomalous this morning what we're
looking at what we're focusing on this
morning so yeah okay inequalities and
how they were different two equations
correct however you might recall we
focused on a very specific family of
equations and inequalities but really
the simplest kind you could deal with
because they were all notice lots of
help they're all linear very good which
is why that last example I showed you
those straight lines and you saw they're
quite easy to wrap your head around and
we're going to step it up a little bit
you see quadratics before we're still in
that part of the course for to unit
where things still feel familiar enough
from last year but we're just going to
look a lot of hot on vacations it does
okay sure let me start with something
that you know we have established three
different methods that we can choose
from really for solving quadratic
equations anyone want to suggest one of
them yeah families okay so because Q
suggests one for me what's another
method that we can use yeah so okay so
I'll pause for a second I'll put this
here
I think what we're thinking and this is
still visual I think possibly what we're
thinking of with these two I'm not so
much quadratic equations by simultaneous
equations now those skills are still
useful because all of the stuff that you
do algebraically with simultaneous
equations you can still do them
depending on the quadratic you get what
else could we do yeah okay here we go
so I'm gonna put all of these together
together with these other forms of
algebraic manipulation really what we're
trying to get to is that's with an F
when we looked at a lot last week
factorizing if you're going to do any
elimination or substitution the kinds
that you're going to do other ones that
get you closer to a factorization right
and it's the same with grouping you
might have four terms in your expansion
there you could say well these two I can
pull out a common factor these two and
off you go
okay but these are only the simplest
clients if you want to do this kind of
algebraic manipulation you've gotta have
to really have a very straightforward
quadratic right sometimes not so easy
you can't think of a pair of numbers
that will easily go into so what other
kinds of techniques do you have you
don't okay
the quadratic formula by now I wonder if
we can recite it hmm
x equals - babe muscle - whoa okay stop
stop that was awful let's try again
together you're like I got to the end
yeah but not ever knows it okay count of
three this time you ready 1 2 3 minus B
plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac all over okay so good
you know a formula but what happened
lost what goes in the middle there's
something else that we need to know and
you've learnt already I'm gonna fix it
today before you get to the quadratic
formula how do you get it it's okay
difference of squares we have been
looking at over there factorization
I think however you don't always get
something that's so neat in a quadratic
that's just a difference of squares
sometimes even when you have something
very messy and in fact this technique
it's in the middle you can use with any
quadratic hmm
higher order polynomials we do get to in
time but for now we're thinking just
when you're squaring okay
what do you reckon with huh
that's right that's death that's the
response that most people give okay now
what we're gonna do here is I'm sort of
gonna skip over this because we've done
this to death last week you guys are
really good at factorizing you want to
make sure you're equal to zero and then
you can identify your solutions okay but
this guy over here we're less familiar
with it we don't like it because we find
it difficult and awkward so I want to
push on it a little bit and I want to
remind you that that's actually how we
get the quadratic formula the quadratic
formula is just kind of an automation of
completing the square okay